when you're getting started in business
and you don't have a network you don't
have connections i mean you kind of have
to be
more innovative than any of your
competitors if if you want to
get a foothold in it um and you've and
you've done that
time and time and time again um to kind
of share that story
about uh cannabis clinics sorry canadian
cannabis clinics and canvas rx
um i remember you came over to my office
with your partner at the time with a
investment just to put some money into
that when you guys were just starting to
raise your
uh first first rounds of funding it was
the same week that i had another lawyer
come to my office try to buy my book of
business for cents and a dollar i think
you know who i'm talking about
yeah but um um
you know i looked at that i was like
dude they're not going to prove this man
they're not going to legalize weed in
canada that's not happening
here we are in 2020 it's like fully
legal you can buy whatever you want from
like the government is now the drug
dealer
yeah you know you came up with this
concept of um
kind of kind of cracking the legislative
code that was coming through the
pipelines for
the approval for additional use
and i mean embarrassed me
here but i know all the information's
public but obviously i pass on the
opportunity as an early investor
and um you know you sold to a much
larger corporation
aurora cannabis how much did i lose out
on i mean you must have
walked away with a triple quadruple even
larger digit
multiple right yeah i mean i'm not so
good at doing the math in my head
but um you would have invested at a a
six million dollar evaluation i think we
were talking about maybe investing let's
say a hundred grand yeah and a six
million dollar valuation
we sold the company for a purchase price
of
37 million dollars so there's a six
bagger right there but the thing was is
that
a big chunk of the purchase price was
paid in aurora stock at 40 cents
uh over the next two years aurora went
from 40 cents to 16
so with that that's another 20 bagger on
top of that so
you're you know your 100 grand could
have turned into
a lot of money is is what it boiled down
to and in that case you know
to be fair it wasn't that i was uh
i i didn't it wasn't a legal kind of
analysis i just kind of saw where the
the
trend line was pointing which was
cannabis was becoming ubiquitous
you know they had essentially created a
program where they were creating these
large corporations growing cannabis
you know once you create that kind of
capital markets dynamic
um it's gonna be hard to turn back the
engine
uh that that was the insight there i
think you know one of my
and it has nothing to do with being a
lawyer i just i think i've been
gifted with an ability to see where
trendlines are going by and large in the
future
um and uh getting in front of that and
certainly
you know uh from cannabis to now field
trip that's one of those things which
was
this is gonna happen you know most
people don't realize it was gonna happen
and
for a long time i wasn't convinced but
then certain things fell into place and
now like
you know i guess that was six years ago
we met in your office and and
we're on the cusp of legalizing cannabis
and and you know six years later
uh we're on the cusp of legalizing
psychedelics as well um
you know which is crazy seven years ago
i never would have guessed we'd be
sitting in this position but
no i was dude i was sitting there going
this is this is not i
i just can't see this happening i just
can't see them allowing
you know the canadian populations just
you know recreationally
i mean like even at the time you were
talking about medicinal use which which
had uh you know proven peer
reviewed benefits um you know it existed
right
so and then it was kind of supposed to
lean into um
recreational use and that of course
happened very quickly soon after so
um yeah bravo i mean like you you know
you
you uh you know you took a stake in the
industry you saw
a trend coming and it ended up working
out for you i mean
had i had i invested that 100 grand at
that time
i could have probably bought a
ferrari laferrari a porsche 918
uh maybe mclaren p1 and a bugatti veyron
just kind of top it all off instead of
the one r8 that i've got right now but
you know
um i didn't have a crystal ball to
appear into the future none of us do
it's just one of those things that you
have to take
uh take a stab at in life and at that
time you were
you're playing hard to win and it and it
was a bit of a gamble but it you know
it paid off big time for you um you know
thankfully
with with the organizations and some of
the guys that you know we've all talked
to
and um you know been at men's retreats
and
groups with i also made some subsequent
investments that still caught like the
top end of the trend
um and made some money there as well but
uh
you